this is a Lima hadaki thank you very
much for being with us so so tell us a
little bit more because you research
this story how hard was it to get people
on camera for it oh my very difficult it
was a very very challenging report to do
and we found out that even players for
example who've talked about this topic
in the past that does not necessarily
mean that they want to talk about it
again so and we can understand that
because it's a very sensitive and
emotional topic for them and we also
found out there trying to find an active
players or somebody currently right now
playing that's almost impossible to do
so the ones that are often willing to
talk about it but even they are very
reluctant those are often retired
players or players near the end of their
career because it's a lot safer for them
and they have a lot less to lose why do
you think it's so difficult for them oh
um I can go after having talked what are
the risks of coming out oh very huge so
for example for one of them there's
still a very huge stigma attached to
mental illness there's also a double
standard in the way we treat mental
illness and physical injuries so for
example if you have cancer that will
never be seen as a weakness but in
football for example it has a very
strong match or cultures or and if for
example you say you are depressed you
are sad that seen as a weakness and fall
out of these players they don't want to
be made and the laughingstock in the
change room and at the end of the day
the risk is just too huge because these
are players who could lose their
contract and these are players who and
yeah might not afraid of losing their
positions or it's better to remain quiet
and suffer in silence okay and um I just
want to confirm actually with my
production team I understand that I
think that we have finally the piece on
this story is that correct if so fired
away team that was talked about as the
new Wayne roni and I like scored early
in the games and was
was having success Chelsea was there
watching and I ax I was protecting
practicing with and some yeah somewhere
there around 16 it a lot started to
basically kick off after Latin
Ibrahimovic Martin bankson was one of
the most gifted talents emerging from
Sweden he captained the Swedish
under-17s and before long he got a call
from Inter Milan but what started as a
dream soon turned into a nightmare
Martin tried to take his own life and
he's not alone a 2015 study showed more
than a third of players were suffering
from symptoms of mental health problems
it said that depression is more
widespread among footballers than in
society in general it affects both
current and retired players many of whom
also suffer from sleeping problems and
alcohol abuse active players up to four
times more at risk if they have had
three or more injuries
it was an injury during Martin's first
yet inter that triggered his problems
when you play so much football it's the
only way to value yourself so it's old
always about the game you're never
better than your that your latest game
or train the medical staff at Inter did
not pick up on Martin's depression some
even thought he had epilepsy the
football players union 5th pro one's
mental health issues to be treated the
same as physical injuries it's a joint
responsibility from all stakeholders so
organizing body wave we prepped perhaps
directing the club's to do something and
the club as an employer as also the
responsibility to take care of the
health of the players Martin Bengston
has come a long way since that fateful
day he's got a new life now but he also
campaigns for change and to educate
aspiring footballers on the importance
of having a plan B ok we rejoined now of
course by the reporter who worked on
this piece and worked on this story
olema hadaki so let's just talk for a
minute about about the player who we
just saw there Robert Anka why did his
team not pick up on this and ok um ok
that was actually Martin Bengston and in
the piece size me it's ok but yeah in
Germany for example they also had their
own and where they learned a lot because
Robert anchor for example he changed a
lot in terms of when it came comes to
raising the awareness of many comes to
mental health problems in Germany so he
actually is a very sad story because he
was supposed to be the next big thing
after Oliver Kahn very talented
goalkeeper he committed suicide in 2009
but Germany did learn a lot so after
this incident for example Germany they
created a hotline that's available to
the players there's counselors and
psychologists available to players and
change has been slow but it's also been
happening in other countries so for
example as you saw in this report with
Martin so instead of alienate
him the swedish football associated
association decided let's work with him
so he goes across the country and he
speaks to players of all ages and he
educates them about the importance of
having a plan B in England there's more
workshops now being done when it comes
to educating clubs and players about
mental illness so yeah positive in a
negative so it's clear that more is
definitely being done by by these
various clubs and we heard some
suggestions there in the piece as well
of what else could be done do you get
the sense from from you know speaking
with both the players and and with
authorities and experts that enough is
being done though that that it will
prevent issues like yeah and that's a
really good question because um it is
moving in the right direction but like
you said we can still do a lot better so
for example UEFA for example they have a
lot of power there in my in my opinion
they should be pushing the agenda a lot
stronger like they've done with racism
and kicking out homophobia and all of
that and it also needs to be a lot more
focus on psychiatrists and not just
sports psychologists concerned with
boosting confidence levels and
performance levels and last for lastly
from the players that I've talked to a
lot of players they want anonymity so
for them it's some some of them they
want to see cal but as that help needs
to come from independently funded
psychologists or psychiatrists and it
has to be happening outside of the club
okay so much left to be done olema
hadaki from our sports desk thank you
very much for this exclusive reporting
we appreciate it